let's move on now to look at that new
scheme that's being launched to try and
make it easier for shoppers to recycle
and reuse packaging which we heard about
earlier it's designed to help encourage
people to purchase items in packaging
that they then return to the store so it
can be cleaned refilled and reused but
are small solutions enough to make a big
difference or do they in fact distract
from the large scale measures that are
needed and when you look here you can
really get a sense of the scale of the
problem there i mean i want to get both
of your views um on that do you and
packaging is an immense problem isn't it
you can see that there in the quantity
of it and do you think we think enough
about it or does it get lost in the
debate about what we eat measured
it does get lost at times and it's a
great start but and it's not enough
jealousy obviously reusable packages
changing your diet and other behaviors
like that is a step in the right
direction because i do believe that
when people actually kind of unite in
their activism which those small changes
are large large scale changes can
actually happen however that being said
like we must kind of really stay
vigilant and continue to put pressure on
companies and other elected and our
elected representatives to kind of
create that fair sustainable just world
that we desperately need to save the
planet because if we're only going to be
focused on
small and and individual acts we'll kind
of lose sight of the main culprits on
this it's not individual people like my
uncle abdul or stacy from greg's that's
responsible for two-thirds of all global
emissions it's 90 companies which our
government subsidizes so as well as
doing our small bit and repackaging
everything we kind of need to kind of
also make sure that we put in our
attention kind of holding those people
into accounts yeah well nobody's blaming
abdul and uh and stacy i should say uh
what do you think zion do you think um
this is just tinkering around the edges
it's only ten stores it's only some
products does it miss the bigger issues
like haulage and food production
i think the thing is that what we're
seeing is that this debate is always
framed as an either or when it should be
both but it should be weighted so as an
example recently the extinction
rebellion scientists actually leaked a
draft report of the upcoming ipcc uh
report it's a draft of course but what
it suggested is that if 10 to 30 percent
of our citizenry actually did the good
work of reducing our emissions eating
less meat fewer air cons less flights
what we'd actually be able to do by 2030
is actually reduce emissions to the
equivalent of two brazils and change
those social norms so this is actually
quite fundamental to change but keep in
mind that's 10 to 30 percent the other
70 to 90 percent what needs to happen
there is enlightened policy making
regulation you need to have corporate
impact that is the heavy lifting that
has to be done the one thing i like
about the tesco loop project we have it
here in canada too we have it at loblaws
is it's actually just a twist on an old
idea it's the milkman model you're
paying for the milk you're not paying
for the bottle okay so if the company is
incentivized to keep making better
packaging that lasts a long time that we
can reuse again and again then that does
start to make a difference